Against The Ice is
the tense historical tale
of two arctic explorers,
Ejnar Mikkelsen
and Iver Iversen,
who must survive
the sub-zero conditions
of Greenland
as they seek discoveries of
an earlier expedition.
Based on the book
Two Against The Ice
by Ejnar Mikkelsen himself,
this remarkable story
of survival
in the early 20th century
might seem like it was
dreamt up for a movie.
In fact, director Peter
Flinth first read the book
when it was given to him by
Queen Margrethe II
of Denmark,
who thought it would make
a beautiful film.
But it is an account
of real history
and the resulting drama
sticks close to the events
of Mikkelsen and Iversen's
journey as they happened.
Here's the true story behind
Against The Ice.
Let's start with
the Denmark Expedition,
which is mentioned
throughout the film
as the reason that
Mikkelsen and Iversen
make
their initial excursion.
This is why we're here,
boys.
Without these findings,
the north of Greenland
could be lost,
claimed by the Americans.
In the events that happened
before Against The Ice
begins,
the Denmark Expedition saw
a crew
led by
Ludvig Mylius-Erichsen
set out to map
the last parts
of northeast Greenland.
At the time
of their journey,
which took place
between 1906 and 1908,
it was believed that a lake
called the Peary Channel
cut Greenland in two.
Mylius-Erichsen formed
a smaller team,
composed of cartographer
Niels Peter Høeg Hagen
and native Greenlander
Jørgen Brønlund,
to investigate
whether or not
the Peary Channel
actually existed.
Why don't any of you want to
go with them?
You saw the map.
I mean, it's like walking
from Moscow to Rome
looking for
a stack of stones.
During that journey,
the trio ran into
various hardships,
such as mild weather
melting the ice
they would need to cross
to get back to their ship
and, eventually,
all three succumbed to
the extreme conditions
they faced.
Brønlund's body
was discovered
in a makeshift cave,
which the film alludes to
in one scene,
while the bodies of
Mylius-Erichsen
and Høeg Hagen
were never found.
Anyone would think
you can't make it.
You always believe
there'll be a way.
However, the
Denmark Expedition proved
the Peary Channel
didn't exist
and left information of
their discovery in a can.
As we hear early on
in the film…
What's a can?
A can's a stack of stones
you can see from far away.
Explorers often used these
to store messages
and reports for others.
More importantly,
it provided a way
for the discovery
to be passed on
to other explorers.
This is where the heroes of
Against The Ice come in:
the mystery of
the Denmark Expedition's
fate-gripped explorers
of the time,
including Ejnar Mikkelsen,
played in the film by
Nikolaj Coster-Waldau.
Mikkelsen was commissioned
to lead a search
to find Mylius-Erichsen
and his research.
He put together
a small crew,
seen briefly in the film,
and set off in the ship
The Alabama
on the 20th of June 1909.
However, what we don't see
in the film is
how Mikkelsen came to be
commissioned for this trip.
The sailor was
originally approached by
Lord Northcliffe,
the owner of the Daily Mail
at the time,
and proposed
that he fund a trip
for Mikkelsen to find
the dead men's papers.
In return,
anything he found would be
published in the newspaper.
Mikkelsen liked
the sound of the offer,
however revealed in his book
that he felt:
"As a Dane,
I did not like the idea of
an Englishman paying for
the expedition
and of his money acquiring
the rights to
what three Danes had given
their lives to achieve".
Mikkelsen went
back to Denmark
and approached the committee
who first commissioned
the Denmark Expedition
about leading a mission to
retrieve the missing papers.
They agreed to pay
half the cost of the trip,
with Mikkelsen funding
the rest.
The crew travelled to
where Brønlund's body
was discovered
and, in the spring of 1910,
Mikkelsen and the crew's
engineer, Iver Iversen,
played by Joe Cole,
set out to see
if they could find the can
that Brønlund's notes
alluded to.
The perilous journey to find
the can is based on
the first-hand accounts
Mikkelsen wrote in his book,
as is
the even harder journey
they had to make back.
This is what happened to
Mylius-Erichsen, isn't it?
Another part of
the return journey
that the film alludes to is
the men's struggle for food.
On my calculations,
I've lost us
two weeks' worth
of dog food.
I've lost us half our tea
and one can of paraffin.
While we see the pair
having to rely on eating
some rather foul things,
the book reveals that
they even resorted to
eating mould.
As Iversen is claimed
to have said:
"You said
we need vegetables!
Isn't mould also
a kind of vegetable?"
To be clear, it is not.
Despite having to trek back
on foot
and without supplies,
their ordeal was
far from over.
When they arrived back at
their camp in November 1910,
they discovered that
the crew had abandoned them,
just like in the film,
leaving them only with
a small wooden hut
made from their ship,
The Alabama,
hence why it's dubbed
Alabama Cottage in the film
and Alabama Hudson
in real life,
and supplies to last them
through the winter.
They left us!
No!
Amazingly, Mikkelsen
and Iversen survived
in this small cabin,
having to fend off
physical dangers,
such as
an attack from a bear,
as well as
the mental effects
of such extreme isolation.
I met my grandfather
earlier.
Your grandfather?
Here?
No, just up on the hill.
Where the film differs from
reality
is that their ordeal was
even harder in real life.
Take, for instance,
the bear attack that occurs
late in the film.
While the movie shows
Mikkelsen and Iversen
scaring off the bear
by making loud noises,
in Mikkelsen's book
he recounts
how this attack saw
the bear actually
make its way into the hut,
kicking up steam
from a pan of water
that had been boiling
on the stove
and Iversen having to
shoot it to death.
In a stroke of luck,
something that,
up until that point,
had been in short supply
for both of them,
they were discovered
by a passing Norwegian ship
on July 21st 1912.
They had been separated from
any other human contact
for almost 28 months.
Despite the hardships
they endured,
some elements
of their journey live on,
such as the Alabama Cottage.
The hut in which Mikkelsen
and Iversen survived
is still standing
and, in 2016,
was completely restored
by the northeast Greenland
company Nanok
for
the North Greenland Museum.
Bringing Mikkelsen's story
to life
has also been a passion
project for Coster-Waldau,
who was sent
a copy of the book
by his close friend
Peter Flinth in 2011.
He said about
making the film:
"It combines a lot of themes
that excite me:
adventure, Greenland,
companionship,
loyalty and love".
The actor also has
a personal connection
to Greenland:
his wife,
actor and singer Nukaaka,
is from the country.
You can watch how Mikkelsen
and Iversen's story unfolds
in Against The Ice streaming
on Netflix now.
And, for more true stories
behind
your favourite shows
and films,
why not subscribe to
Still Watching Netflix?